ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález ecuador está
bajo estado de excepción por 60 días
ante el incremento de la violencia en lo
corrido del año este país ya ha
registrado alrededor de 1900 asesinatos
una cifra superior si la comparamos con
el año 2020 que fue de 1400 personas
asesinadas qué significa este estado de
excepción permitirá el traslado de las
fuerzas armadas también a las provincias
donde los ciudadanos han sentido el
incremento de la inseguridad siendo
estas las provincias de guayas manabí
santa elena el oro los ríos esmeraldas
santodomingo pichincha y sucumbíos los
militares van entonces a reforzar las
labores de la policía nacional en las
calles y también las autoridades podrán
restringir el movimiento la reunión y
asociación de los habitantes veamos más
detalles en el siguiente reportaje
preparado por la redacción de france 24
una reunión en las primeras horas del
estado de excepción y una muestra de
apoyo contundente sister james wan en
las democracias hay momentos y
circunstancias excepcionales y las
medidas son necesarias para lidiar con
urgencias y con situaciones urgentes
como la que ecuador está experimentando
ahora a la 46 transit now en paralelo el
encuentro comenzaron los operativos de
las fuerzas armadas en el primer día del
estado de excepción que tiene el
objetivo de frenar una ola de violencia
que atraviesa el país relacionada con el
tráfico de drogas los militares
controlan vehículos y hacen requisas en
diferentes partes del país
aproximadamente a las 10 de la mañana se
detuvieron a dos personas fueron puestas
a órdenes de la policía nacional ya que
transportaban sustancia sueca la
fiscalización específicamente heroína el
estado de excepción permite que las
fuerzas armadas puedan restringir el
movimiento y las reuniones además de la
confiscación de armas y drogas durante
los próximos 60 días la medida ha sido
criticada por algunos sectores políticos
y defensores de los derechos humanos las
fuerzas armadas están entrenadas para la
guerra no para el control del orden
público y la criminalidad esto debe ser
excepcional temporal y estrictamente
necesario o se prestará para graves
abusos hace un mes 119 personas murieron
en una cárcel en guayaquil situación que
el gobierno le atribuyó a los
enfrentamientos entre bandas de
narcotraficantes en lo que va del año
ecuador registra 1900 asesinatos más de
los 1400 de todo el año pasado
surgen muchas preguntas hay muchos
puntos para analizar sobre la mesa es
esta medida suficiente para aplacar la
creciente ola de delincuencia y también
el crimen organizado cuando ecuador se
convirtió en un país de tránsito para
las rutas del narcotráfico qué va a
pasar en este país después de los 60
días que tanta presión es sobre el
presidente guillermo lasso que poco más
de cinco meses ha estado en el cargo de
la presidencia lo vamos a analizar aquí
en el debate de france 24 y para hablar
de estos temas hemos invitado a fausto
jarrín terán asambleísta provincial por
la alianza une se les ecuatoriano se
encuentra en la ciudad de quito la
capital ecuatoriana también está con
nosotros fernando carrión analista
político y también académico de flacso
ecuador también se encuentra en la
ciudad de quito en la capital
ecuatoriana y aquí en el estudio de
france 24 está con nosotros sergio
guzmán analista internacional y director
de colombia risca análisis ustedes
también nuestros televidentes pueden
participar también pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos como
24s
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 paramos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en torno a
este tema vamos a comenzar con la
pregunta para conocer posiciones en
torno a este tema y comienzo acá en el
estudio de france 24 sergio guzmán
gracias por estar con nosotros y el
estado de excepción es la el primer paso
que se puede dar para comenzar a darle
una solución a esta situación de
inseguridad que está viviendo ecuador
oeste es un tema mucho más grande que va
más allá de 60 días que creo que es
hacia el escenario si evidentemente
cuando estamos hablando de esto hay que
mirarlo con una perspectiva de largo
plazo la pandemia el coronavirus fue
primero una crisis de salud que se tornó
en una crisis económica y ahora estamos
viendo el coletazo de la crisis de
seguridad y esto no es un asunto
exclusivo de ecuador- estamos viendo lo
mismo en colombia estamos viendo lo
mismo en perú estamos viendo lo mismo en
otros países el estado de excepción en
realidad lo que está mostrando es que el
gobernante se encuentra
opciones políticas para salir a la calle
y decir tengo una solución entonces la
militarización ofrece una herramienta
muy fácil que no necesariamente es
efectiva para contrarrestar la oleada
criminal que tiene un profundo origen en
la falla de la economía del lugar y en
este caso el incremento de los precios y
la reducción de subsidios vamos aquí
todo fausto jarrín buenas noches allí en
la capital ecuatoriana y el estado de
excepción es el punto de partida para
comenzar a solucionar estos temas de
seguridad que está presentando ecuador
muchas gracias santiago un saludo a
france24 un saludo para latinoamérica un
saludo también para sergio en esta en el
estudio y como no para el catedrático
fernando carrión que nos acompaña
también desde la ciudad de quito
realmente
y más allá del análisis jurídico que
podemos hacer de los gravísimos errores
que tiene el decreto decepción en lo en
lo formal en lo material una carencia de
especificidades vale decir que en el
ecuador venimos decretando nos en
excepción por ejemplo el sistema
carcelario creo que por quinta o sexta
vez desde el año 2018 y no ha tenido
ninguna posibilidad ni ha generado
ninguna posibilidad cierta de contener
lo que hemos venido sintiendo en
inseguridad estoy completamente de
acuerdo con sergio el ecuador es un país
que no tomó medidas para contener la
crisis económica que se tenía como
producto de la pandemia y más allá de
los hechos violentos que de ninguna
manera pueden ser justificables lo que
le sucede al país es que estamos
viviendo los coletazos extremadamente
violentos de una crisis económica que ha
puesto en necesidades extremas a las
familias del ecuador me parece que es
una medida completamente
inapropiada espero que de alguna manera
se pueda contener la ola delictiva pero
la violencia es real que estamos
viviendo el producto de la crisis de la
pandemia no se va a controlar con el
ejército
desgraciadamente esa es la sensación que
tengo yo y seguimos en quito- seguimos
en la capital ecuatoriana
fernando carrión analista político
bienvenido al programa y la misma
pregunta como punto de partida de esta
situación y también punto de partida el
programa
bueno un saludo cordial
santiago a toda la audiencia y
obviamente a fausto jarrín ya ya sergio
plantearía algunos datos que me parece
que son importantes en el tema
carcelario del 2010 al 2017 se tuvo un
promedio anual de 10 personas que
fallecieron por año a partir de ese año
en el año 2018 subieron a 32 en el 2019
subieron a 54 y hoy día hemos pasado ya
de los 240 asesinatos dentro de las
cárceles ahí hay una pregunta respecto
de por qué el 2018 si nosotros vamos
también por la línea de los homicidios
en el año 2018 tuvimos 1
991 homicidios da la impresión que este
año vamos a terminar probablemente con
el triple de homicidios en otras
palabras tanto las políticas que son
prácticamente lo que ocurre en el
sistema carcelario porque el resultado
las políticas para la gente empresa y
por otro lado los hechos delictivos que
están aconteciendo lo que nos es que el
año 2017 y 2018 se produce un quiebre
fundamental y aquí hay que entender que
hay dos tipos de violencia la una es la
violencia común que es básicamente
problemas contra el patrimonio robos y
hurtos que han crecido y el otro es
asesinatos contra las personas y la
segunda forma de violencia es el
narcotráfico que es lo que nosotros
estamos estamos teniendo estamos viendo
un crecimiento de los dos porque porque
la violencia como un producto de la
crisis económica que viene como señalaba
a sergio que viene principalmente del
cobit hay un problema de crisis
económica y un proceso de pobreza el
problema de empleo y en el caso del
narcotráfico el ecuador ya no es un país
exclusivamente el tránsito el ecuador es
un país de lavado desde que tenemos la
dolarización en el cambio de siglo soy
el ecuador es un país que produce
cocaína y el ecuador es un país que
consume
fernando sigo con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa dejo a sergio de
último pero no porque sea menos
importante sino para para hacer la ronda
a la inversa y quiero que partamos de
ese punto que usted señala en cuanto al
narcotráfico
en qué momento ecuador y qué condiciones
se dieron para que dejara de ser un país
de tránsito para que fuera un país que
fuera un eslabón importante en la cadena
del narcotráfico internacional y que
fueron los componentes allí localmente
que permitieron que esto sucediera
lo que ha ocurrido es que nosotros en el
ecuador montamos un mito que nosotros
nos definimos como una isla de paz que
esto surgió a fines del siglo pasado
principalmente porque en colombia
estaban las farc el ejército liberación
nacional quintín la alma etcétera y en
el perú estaba sendero luminoso mrt hay
otros grupos y en el ecuador no y esa
misma tesis se planteó frente al tema
del narcotráfico pero qué es lo que
ocurrió en el primer caso no hubo
contaminación y en el segundo si el
ecuador empieza a producir cocaína a
partir del año
2006 esto no significa que nosotros
seamos cultivadores no somos
cultivadores de coca pero si son los
productores de cocaína porque el plan
colombia lo que generó fue lo que
algunos autores denominan el efecto
globo salieron o salió de esa fase de
colombia y se vino al ecuador la segunda
cosa somos un país de lavado más o menos
en el guards hablaba entre un 3 o 4 por
ciento del pib una cantidad muy grande
mal aguador no así para el mercado de
drogas pero eso es muy grande y eso se
hace principalmente a partir de que el
ecuador se dolariza en el año 99 el año
2000 en el año 2014 el ecuador empieza a
consumir
narcóticos del ecuador no era un país de
consumo y el ecuador consume más o menos
del 18 por ciento de lo que pasa por
aquí que son entre 80 y 100 toneladas
plata y conjunto de cosas lo que nos
está mostrando es que por ejemplo el
sicariato que antes el asesino mataba a
una persona que no tenía historia
criminal a lo que está ocurriendo este
momento en que tanto el asesino como el
asesinado tienen una historia criminal
porque nuestro sistema carcelario no
rehabilita fausto le hago la misma
pregunta qué es lo que está pasando en
ecuador' cuáles son las condiciones que
se están dando hay una falta de
presencia estatal para que se están
conjugando todos estos factores que se
han venido presentando en los últimos
años y están repuntando en este momento
con esta ola de violencia que ustedes
están viviendo
efectivamente sin sin discrepar de lo
que plantea
fernando
hay que dejar algunas cosas sentadas
respecto de la situación de la violencia
y una de ellas es la destrucción de todo
el esquema de seguridad que empieza con
el gobierno de lenin moreno hacia
alrededor de cuatro años y medio se
elimina el ministerio de justicia lo
poco que se había logrado general en
relación a las posibilidades de
rehabilitación del sistema carcelario
que realmente haba razón como se decía
antaño escuelas del delito se tira por
la borda se elimina el ministerio se
acaba todo el esquema de rehabilitación
se eliminan los ministerios
coordinadores la seguridad vuelve a
unificarse con el esquema político en
los últimos años vimos a un ministerio
de gobierno dedicado a comprar
voluntades en la asamblea sin
absolutamente irresponsable de lo que le
sucedía al país y ahora desgraciadamente
estamos viendo las consecuencias de ese
abandono estatal que efectivamente se ve
además
agravado por justamente lo que dice
fernando en la dolarización el hecho de
que en el ecuador se está lavando dinero
y de que en el ecuador ya no solamente
es un sistema de paso creo que el tema
del consumo no debería de ninguna manera
motivar un estado de emergencia pero si
el hecho de que acá se está produciendo
cocaína y desde aquí ya se ha generado
el interés de los carteles mexicanos
sobre todo suizo también ha venido con
la violencia que esto implica así que la
situación es estructural es
extremadamente grave y vuelvo a
coincidir con sergio en esto un gobierno
sin una capacidad de opciones políticas
tiene que recurrir a la militarización y
eso es bastante delicado paso al estudio
de france 24 sergio a preguntarle aquí
entonces está fallando la presencia
estatal es un poco un escenario similar
a lo que se ve en otros países
latinoamericanos acaso colombia acaso el
salvador honduras
sobre todo las que tienen serios
problemas de narcotráfico pero la
militarización entonces si es la
solución para empezar a hacer presencia
estatal en que está fallando el gobierno
y exactamente para para dar el primer
paso no miren la militarización es es
una opción pero entre más tiempo dure la
militarización más rabia y más escozor
puede haber por situaciones devengadas
de violaciones de derechos humanos
pueden haber fallas en procedimientos
que se vuelvan virales y que eso mismo
se vuelve un detonante de protesta pero
yo creo que una cosa que usted mencionó
es muy importante que es que la cadena
del narcotráfico viene desde estados
unidos pasa por méxico y sigue hacia
centro y suramérica no hay una
cooperación entre todos los distintos
países para luchar en contra de los
grupos narcotraficantes en contra del
lavado de dinero pero tampoco
o sea se está tratando de plantear la
misma solución que ya conocemos como
fallida entonces a menos de que se
cambie el plante de cierta forma esta
tendencia que está describiendo nuestros
colegas en quito no va a cambiar y a
nivel local según lo han denunciado
diferentes medios ecuatorianos también
algunas de las autoridades han
mencionado que allí hay grandes cárteles
colombianos y mexicanos haciendo
presencia esto usted lo dice la lucha
que están dando es un es un formato que
ya hemos visto que no funciona en otros
países cómo enfrentar entonces a estos
carteles que están empezando a
aprovecharse de esa falta estatal y
están viendo oportunidades de hacer
presencia en otros países de la región
que anteriormente no tenían historial de
ser parte de las cadenas del
narcotráfico por supuesto y la
descentralización
de la cadena logística del narcotráfico
un punto cuando el los cárteles
mexicanos también empiezan a hacer lo
que se llama una integración vertical
del negocio en donde cada vez más están
involucrados en el cultivo en el
tránsito desde el destino
el origen del producto pues ahí vamos a
ver que estas organizaciones se van a
tornar más violentas más presión contra
el estado y contra las fuerzas estatales
y desafortunadamente ni en ecuador ni en
perú ni en colombia ni en méxico ni en
centroamérica estamos preparados para
esa integración vertical fernando en la
ciudad de quito 60 días ha planteado el
gobierno a través de este estado de
excepción para poder mirar qué
estrategia puede hacer esta estrategia
también incluye ayuda internacional hace
unas cuantas horas estaba el secretario
de estado de eeuu anthony blinken ayer
en ecuador y vio con buenos ojos esta
decisión del gobierno de ecuador eeuu
puede empezar a colaborar en esta lucha
contra la contra la violencia desatada a
raíz del narcotráfico
a ver yo lo que creo también con las con
las
fechas que estoy planteando 2008 hacia
adelante y en eso coincidió con fausto
hay otro elemento fundamental respecto
de la política de narcóticos en la misma
línea está del ecuador como una isla de
paz y un país de tránsito entonces el
ecuador lo que empieza a hacer desde el
2008 es privilegiar el mercado externo
del ecuador si ustedes ven el decreto de
emergencia básicamente son las
provincias de la costa que es por donde
sale la droga donde hay la mayor
cantidad de municipios y la frontera con
colombia que es por donde entra la droga
entonces básicamente lo que hace es
enfrentar o de diseñar una política para
enfrentarla la droga desde la
perspectiva del mercado externo es decir
la exportación pero aquí no sólo lo que
es eso sino que es el único mercado que
se trabaja es la cuenca del pacífico por
eso es que generalmente nosotros
hablamos de los cárteles mexicanos de
los cárteles colombianos y no se trabaja
la cuenca del río amazonas es decir
brasil y brasil es el segundo país de
consumo de cocaína y el primero de
carácter el mundo y otra cosa adicional
por brasil sale la droga hacia europa
asia y oceanía porque no se trabaja eso
porque tenemos un privilegio del trabajo
de la droga que es va hacia el norte
básicamente hacia los eeuu por eso es
que hablamos de los carteles mexicanos y
colombianos pero de los brasileños yo
tengo la certeza de que en el ecuador
este el primer comando de la capital que
es del brasil y el comando vermelho
también de brasil también está acá y
porque esto porque nosotros no vemos eso
mucha de la droga que sale por el
ecuador se va así hacia italia aquí está
la ndrangheta que es una de los de los
carteles más grandes que hay en el mundo
superior incluso al cártel de sinaloa
dentro en una crisis después del juicio
que le siguieron a chapo guzmán yo creo
que aquí una de las cosas que tiene que
hacer el ecuador es privilegiar la
política para el consumo interno y
dentro de eso privilegiar las políticas
de salud pública más que las penales
bueno su perspectiva a fausto a esto que
dice fernando privilegiar en la parte
interna políticas de salud
qué piensa usted
estoy completamente de acuerdo por eso
vuelvo a decir la militarización no es
la opción el sistema carcelario basta
volver a tocar las cifras que fernando
ha planteado es en este año en donde
hemos llegado ya a las casi 300 víctimas
dentro de las cárceles y los dos estados
de sección que se han dictado respecto
de las cárceles el 1 que no tuvo decreto
especialmente por un error aparente del
gobierno y el segundo que ya tiene
decreto y que está vigente casi tres
semanas no han servido o al menos no
hemos visto los resultados militarizaron
las cárceles realmente es la política
pública desde desde el mando civil el
que tiene que hacerse cargo de la
situación cualquiera que ver con
narcóticos y más aún si es consumo
interno en el país
usted utilizar esa justificación para
militarizar y va a implicar que la
persecución de los consumidores es
bastante delicada la situación yo
coincido plenamente si aquí se trata de
temas de salud pública aquí se trata de
tratar de recuperar el sistema de
rehabilitación social en el ecuador
venimos viviendo ya desde hace
muchísimos años hemos sido sancionados
varias veces por él el uso de la prisión
preventiva tenemos un hacinamiento
gigantesco en nuestras cárceles y
nuevamente esto no se puede dejar de
decir la situación de la pandemia y la
crisis económica posterior es la que
tiene ese primer grupo de tipos
delictivos como delitos contra el
patrimonio que ya decía fernando y
incrementado de forma vertiginosa a eso
sumado la emigración a eso sumado a una
serie de cosas que han contribuido para
que la situación sea grave y
relativamente en relación más bien dicho
al decreto de excepción tenemos cosas
demasiado delicadas y escuchaba que en
el relato que hacían de la redacción del
medio hablaban de algunos derechos que
estarían restringidos pues
desgraciadamente el decreto no restringe
derechos entonces incumple una de las
obligaciones constitucionales que tiene
tiene una motivación extremadamente vaga
por lo tanto no es una motivación que se
ajuste a la situación yo no sé qué va a
suceder con este decreto en la corte
constitucional entonces acá todavía
queda mucha tela por cortar y mucho que
discutir inclusive sobre las formas en
cómo se plantea este decreto fausto pero
la decisión que ha tomado el gobierno es
apostarle a la militarización
le quiero preguntar por la parte
exactamente el equipamiento con el que
puede contar el ecuador para está este
operativo que va a tener a lo largo de
estos 60 días que los militares van a
llegar como lo explicamos a las
provincias más afectadas por la
seguridad esto requerirá entrenamientos
requerirá compra de armas compra
equipamiento a nivel internacional que
ecuador salga a comprarle a otros países
a nivel internacional para llevar a cabo
estos operativos ya que le apostó
precisamente por la parte militar no por
la parte de salud que lo que estamos
hablando
de hecho el decreto dispone como todo
decreto que el ministerio de finanzas
ponga a las órdenes los recursos
necesarios pero aquí hay un tema muy
delicado si me permiten el artículo 4
del decreto establece en los casos que
durante el estado de sección las fuerzas
armadas a la policía nacional aprendan a
personas cometiendo aparentes
infracciones penales deberá ceñirse
estrictamente al debido proceso y poner
el detenido a órdenes de la autoridad
competente les estamos dando a las
fuerzas armadas y eso unido al discurso
del presidente de que prácticamente se
les va a dar impunidad
y ha puesto en el límite el respeto a
los derechos humanos el respeto a los
estándares internacionales y quien sabe
que es que no más de lo que el ejército
la policía se vaya a intentar proveerse
yo creo que el ejército en el ecuador
estaba provisto de los materiales
necesarios para defender las fronteras
para la seguridad exterior y me imagino
que tendrán que proveerse de elementos
de md mecanismos de materiales para
combatir los temas urbanos para los que
el ejército no está hecho y todo eso
reviste un tema ocupación respecto del
respeto a los derechos humanos y
coincido con sergio mientras más dure
este estado más se podrán ver
violaciones a las garantías
constitucionales y a los derechos
humanos por lo cual lo único que se
generará es consecuencias posteriores
sin que realmente esto logre controlar
la violencia que el ecuador ha vivido si
eso en cuanto entonces a la logística
militar para llevar a cabo esta este
estado decepciones e incremento de la
presencia militar en las provincias
sergio pero lo ha mencionado a los dos
invitados la parte de los derechos
humanos que el ejército pueda usar la
fuerza y vaya un poco más allá de lo que
sus límites le puede permitir aquí
entonces la ciudadanía que
puede hacer al respecto cómo puede
garantizar que se le respeten sus
derechos y que el ánimo de de no pasar
por encima de ellos simplemente pues
pase por encima de los ciudadanos para
poder cumplir con estas metas que se
plantea el gobierno pues yo creo que los
ciudadanos tienen una herramienta que
han utilizado muy frecuentemente durante
los últimos diez años en que su celular
y los ciudadanos están cada vez más
grabando a la policía grabando al
ejército durante los procedimientos y no
toma sino un par de imágenes que se
viralizó para contagiar de indignación a
un montón de personas para que ellos a
su vez salgan a la calle para que eso se
devengue en pronunciamientos de
organizaciones internacionales o de
celebridades internacionales y no hay
que pasar por del lado que el público en
eeuu el público en europa hoy día
conecta muy distinto y mucho más
personalmente con la violencia policial
de lo que había hecho antes entonces ver
un vídeo
o de perú o de colombia o de chile le
mueve la fibra a las demás personas
entonces para las personas con un
celular se vuelve un arma contra el
gobierno contra la autoridad que cada
vez están más prestos a utilizar sergio
y como la mayoría de cosas que sucede en
américa latina esto puede empezar a
generar un efecto bola de nieve de
violencia ya vemos que los carteles los
grandes carteles mexicanos y colombianos
hacen presencia en otros países esta
violencia y este tipo de situaciones
cree usted que pueda empezar a moverse
hacia otros países de la región dado que
también se están dando condiciones por
la pandemia sí yo creo que las
condiciones están prestas para
movilizaciones sociales en distintos
países pero los detonantes en cada país
son distintos es decir puede ocurrir un
evento en ecuador que no tenga un
detonante en colombia en perú en bolivia
en argentina etcétera pero es un evento
en ecuador que devengue en algún tipo de
concesión por parte del gobierno en
algún tipo de cambios en el entorno
político si pueden dar a luz a los que
se manifiestan en otros países y también
buscar ese tipo de concesiones fernando
en la ciudad de quito ya entramos en el
bloque de final del programa le quiero
preguntar por la presión que tiene el
presidente guillermo lasso que solamente
ha estado un poco más de cinco meses en
la presidencia ecuatoriana en qué
condiciones está el presidente de la cee
en este momento en cuanto a apoyos en
cuanto a presiones ciudadana y de los
diferentes sectores políticos a raíz de
este tema
a ver datos datos de los resultados
electorales y de encuestas el presidente
lazo paso la primera vuelta con un poco
más del 19 por ciento gana a la
presidencia a la república con 54 por
ciento y hace un mes estaba con 74 por
ti hoy día según la encuestadora hay
desde 37 40 y 62 por ciento de
aceptación yo creo que el resultado que
nosotros tenemos de esta política del
estado de excepción proviene de esa
caída y porque esto porque en las mismas
encuestas hoy día se ha posicionado en
primer lugar pero dramáticamente la
demanda por seguridad serbios es una
respuesta de este tipo le puedes ver si
esta legitimidad porque eso es lo que se
ha mostrado en los casos de la
militarización en otros países ahora que
esto vaya a resolver el problema yo creo
que no me parece absurdo no se usa
históricamente nosotros hemos visto que
eso no ha ocurrido entonces lo que sí
puede ocurrir es que temporal 20 él
pueda obtener una legitimidad que les
lleve por ejemplo
plantear consulta popular o muerte
cruzada para resolver un problema
complejo que también tiene con la
asamblea nacional en fausto su opinión
al respecto en cuanto al capital
político y lo que se está jugando el
presidente en este momento
a raíz de la crisis carcelaria y dentro
del hecho de la crisis económica de la
que ya venimos discutiendo aquí desde el
principio de esta de este debate luego
de alcanzar como dice fernando un nivel
del 70 a 72 por ciento de aceptación
guillermo lasso empieza a caer
vertiginosamente
y luego se viene el escándalo de pandora
papers donde su figura es una de las
principales figuras que aparece
vinculada con este esquema de
offshores de ocultamiento de recursos de
todo lo que implica este tema de los
paraísos fiscales guillermo lasso este
momento está enfrentando un proceso de
investigación en la asamblea el día de
hoy
se ha negado a asistir a la comisión que
corresponde el país está cotizado
tenemos diversos grupos y gremios y
colectivos sociales saliendo a las
calles y coincide desgraciadamente con
este decreto que a muchos me incluyo nos
da la sensación de que efectivamente
quiere recuperar un poco de ese capital
político a través del discurso de la
seguridad pero es una acción desesperada
para tratar de evitar que la situación
de conmoción que el país vive por todas
estas situaciones
vaya a determinar una situación mucho
más grave en relación a su estabilidad
política así que eso no puedo dejar de
decirlo este decreto decepción tan mal
hecho además de no jurídico puede tener
connotaciones también estratégicas en
relación a la situación personal del
presidente de su familia en su inflar
que ver con los paraísos fiscales y los
pandora papers sergio analizando el tema
de ecuador y analizando la situación del
presidente lazo viéndolo desde afuera
desde fuera de las fronteras
ecuatorianas fausto mencionaba conmoción
y falta de estabilidad
los papeles de pandora estas crisis
recientes que ha enfrentado se están
conjugando allí factores también para
que haya una gran crisis política en
ecuador que es un país que ha tenido
reiteradas crisis políticas y en las que
los ciudadanos toman el poder por la
fuerza y salen a las calles y exigen
como no sucede en muchos otros países de
américa latina' cuadros y tiene un
historial de bajar presidentes en la
calle sí pero yo creo que en este
momento sigue siendo muy temprano para
decir que esta es una crisis no pero
están regresando factores que pueden
degenerar a eso si llevan muchos
elementos que permiten uno decir bueno
aquí si uno de los puntos esto puede
llegar a eso pero en este momento es
sigue siendo muy temprano yo lo que sí
diría es que el presidente lazo tiene en
este momento un más del 50 por ciento de
aprobación más del 50 por ciento de
favorabilidad si vemos esa favorabilidad
descender a los 30 a los 25 etcétera ahí
sí yo creo que sí hay que preocuparse en
este momento todavía no sabemos
definitivamente cómo ha afectado el
escándalo de pandora papers y como
afectado francamente este estado de
excepción al a la imagen del gobierno ya
veremos si se manifiesta algún tipo de
violación de derechos humanos algún tipo
de evento durante el estado de excepción
que profundice esta crisis y leo ante el
malestar social no se olvide
el presidente aún quiere
reducir los subsidios a la gasolina y
eso sí algo si ha sido un detonante
histórico para más movilizaciones
sociales y más protestas bueno pues ahí
lo tienen ustedes factores a tener en
cuenta a futuro para ver cómo se va
ejerciendo tal vez presión por parte de
la ciudadanía dependiendo de los
resultados que vayan teniendo las
diferentes medidas que tome el gobierno
recta final del programa las
conclusiones comenzó con fausto muy
puntual por favor qué es lo que usted
quiere que va a suceder yo siempre lo
digo no tenemos la bola de cristal para
saber el futuro pero cuál piensa usted
que va a ser el desenlace de esta
situación puntual
el desenlace es
absolutamente
oscuro no no no no alcanzo a entender
hasta donde soy el gobierno pretende
llevar este esquema una aclaración para
sergio el subsidio a los combustibles
fue eliminado en el gobierno anterior y
una de las presiones muy fuertes que
tiene el gobierno actual es la de al
menos focalizar algunos de esos
subsidios para tratar de sostener por
ejemplo el transporte público para
tratar de sostener algunas cosas así que
ya la situación y el clima de conmoción
en el país es latente yo personalmente
considero que iremos la soya está por
debajo del 40% esos números de los que
hablas sergio se están acercando
vertiginosamente yo creo que el tema
pasa más por las políticas públicas que
por un esquema de militarización del
país fernando rápidamente por favor su
conclusión yo creo que los resultados de
esta de este estado de decepción los
vamos a ver dentro de 60 días bueno un
poco menos es decir antes antes del
cambio de año y creo que la situación va
a seguir siendo exactamente igual me
parece que se suman también a los
problema de violencia de los problemas
políticos la relación con la asamblea no
es la mejor el bloque el bloque de
gobierno es súper nando para lo cual
tiene que llegar a ser acuerdo acción y
obviamente diez segundos por favor la
conclusión fernando lo tengo que cortar
para poder que sergio termine con su
conclusión yo diría que la tendencia no
es buena y la solución que está
brindando el gobierno puede ser
cortoplacista pero los eventos pueden
detonar una crisis aún más grave pues si
tienen ustedes los puntos de vista de
nuestros invitados gracias por haber
dejado sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
la programación de france 24
[Música]